hello reject nation
I'm Greg Alba look who it is it's Taylor
Robinson from so fine Taylor finally
making cracks with her boy-toy she has
her own channel does reactions on there
as well word has it she might be on the
Schmo down soon no official announcement
yet but who knows maybe maybe oh my
goodness Taylor have you seen the movie
Suicide Squad unfortunately well there's
a DC animated movie about Suicide Squad
called hell to pay
no idea what this is about exactly but I
like the DC animated movies you seen any
of those ah you know you should play in
the inner geek them hi Chris Baker the
day shout-out for Paige and Valente
today wow that's a rated R movie right
Amanda nice she's not black that's weird
oh they're the chips and stuff
[Music]
I didn't sign up to deal with an
immortal butcher you didn't sign up for
anything
one thing this one's off the grid you'll
be dealing with me directly and there
better be some cool [ __ ] either
[Music]
nice
I don't take orders from motorists not
even if I said that killer frost
[Music]
damn you're right admissions together
[Music]
what what exactly is that movie about
movie but no actual plot in there well
thank God for the in do besides task
force x targets a powerful mystical
object that they will risk their lives
to steal to me it looks cool what I like
too is the way the action scenes are
done they kind of have this anime effect
to it but the way the camera Falls
around kind of the shutter frame rate
whenever they're punching and fighting
each other it's has this gritty vibe but
I could really go for here is a red band
trailer though that would be the best
because with the warning I want to show
me the strong bloody violence show me
the brief nudity going on here what I'm
thinking might happen when you watch
this DC animated movie I often feel the
animated movies are better than a lot of
the real-life DC films we've gotten so
far I feel like the impression we'll get
is oh this should have been what the
live-action movie is because this seems
like it'll have still that hyperkinetic
sort of crazy energy about it but the
fact that it's r-rated I think really
aids in whatever story we're gonna get
right now I agree I think that if they
would have gone a direction like this
with the live-action yeah it would have
just blown everybody away I don't even
know what they tried to do I've seen The
Suicide Squad movie I've seen Suicide
Squad on the air over so now there's
this version and there's also the comics
and this team seems to make sense to go
up against something supernatural
because you got some of your realistic
ones but then you also got some of your
supernatural metahumans on the team too
so it just makes sense as opposed to the
movie which have like almost no
metahumans for the most part this seems
like this could be good recovery ground
and I'm wondering if this is part of
their marketing strategy because you're
gonna be doing Suicide Squad - probably
they need to do something to get people
no one is like yeah Suicide Squad - yeah
exactly
exactly and I think they got the voice
of the girl who always does Harley Quinn
to do Harley Quinn I think it's
like this seems like it could be a fun
adventure and I just realized I'm
wearing a Deadpool shirt DC fans are not
sensitive to things like that that's
what I've learned from doing YouTube
Christian Slater is playing dead shot
you know I've always thought that I hate
Will Smith I'd rather see Christian
Slater instead see thomas Howell as
zum-zum Zinn this oh dude oh this is
gonna be sick
Vanessa Williams remember Vanessa
Williams from the movie eraser with
Arnold Schwarzenegger I'm telling you
man they're getting like hot actors
right so how was your first real rejects
video short simple sweet straight to the
point to the point yeah are you
comfortable are you tense you sure I
like my guests to be as uncomfortable
you gotta try a little harder
[Laughter]
I'm gonna look over you see me like
stereo watching all my babe the best
off-camera personality we've had in a
long time
yeah this movie does look really cool I
got away with more stuff in the animated
films and you can get away with in
live-action they used to do cooler stuff
cuz it's all animated you're down for
Hannah made you start an animated movie
you know it's animated playing
flashpoint was rad you see that
flashpoint it's awesome and then Justice
League war
forget about he's a nice crotch doesn't
he
beautiful crush anyway [ __ ] of the day
shoutout for JN Valente Taylor J and
Valente is one of our highest pledged
patrons rarely responds to us when we
try to message him so we can honor his
reward tiers oh but when he does respond
he sends us monologues and rants without
actually giving any clear communication
or response to the question we asked him
so that's thanks for the money on
patreon we just like to keep
your reward tiers buddy and also we
wrote you a letter and we sent you a
shirt it should be on its way he lives
in Portugal Wow
yeah where's that I have no idea I have
no idea in there I'm an American I don't
care about anything outside of the
states absolutely subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified 8th time of videos follow
Taylor Robinson on finely tailored oh I
get the name of your channel now cuz
it's no really finally like ta IO that's
a play on your name with the word okay
Wow clever real clever are ya